talk about new york city we got this in
the daily mail
nyc has worst unemployment rate in the
u.s at 7.6 because manhattan workers and
international tourists still haven't
returned to crime ridden city post kovic
i don't think it's the crime i think
it's the expense i mean if you have a
business that was most people don't like
change most companies don't like change
so if you have a company that's
massively profitable why would you want
to switch your entire management style
and take a giant risk by having
everybody work from home but if your arm
is twisted and you have no choice it's
either a you go out of business or b you
figure out how to make people work from
home you'll figure out how to make
people work from home and then once you
figure out how to make everybody work
from home now you can say you know what
instead of paying 300 000 a month in
rent for the entire floor of this office
what if we just paid 10 for a satellite
office
you're saving 290 000 a month and if
that's the case why are you going to
have everybody return what's the point
like i i've walked home several times
from you know my to my old apartment in
uh bedside from manhattan on 27th street
i i didn't maybe it's just because i'm
used to it or i grew up there i'm
missing something but i haven't felt any
fear of crime on my walk home more than
at least what i've ever felt right but
it's just all these places all these
office buildings all these stores oh
they all say for rent i think that's the
reason it's just if the office workers
haven't returned if the businesses
haven't returned then there's going to
be less work for people think about
think about this too if you're a
business based in new york let's say
you're like buzzfeed right and you all
you really do is you have people sit
around writing articles about stupid
garbage but they could write those
garbage articles anywhere yeah now cost
of living in new york is high it's very
odds i think it's the highest in the in
the country right i think so it goes up
every year goes up every year and plus
new york city has the highest taxes
highest income taxes so
new york state plus city taxes makes
your income your income tax the highest
california as a state has the highest
but i think new york city having like
was that the three percent three or
three and a half percent for city six or
six and a half percent for state yeah
and it goes like i think it's slightly
lower if you make less but that that's
approximately what it is i don't even
think it's the tax that does it i think
it's just the sheer well no not having
to come back to work no no the point i'm
making what i'm pointing out with the
with the taxes is that the cost of
living is high the average person needs
to make like six figures to have a
middle-class life i think new york
state's like 150 to 175k you need to
make to be considered middle-class
because of the cost of living being so
high like three thousand dollars on
average for rent i think it's gone up to
like four
so you're buzzfeed and you're like if i
want to hire someone in new york to come
in the office and write about you know
brad pitt's junk or whatever
i got to spend 175k for mid-tier talent
okay well you know in rural you know
upstate or even in like central pa where
the cost of living is low they can do
the same work we can do virtual meetings
you can metaverse or whatever
we can pay him 60. all right hire the
guy in pa so now the dude who's sitting
in new york who's whose talent uh tree
includes writing about brad pitt's junk
is sitting there like i can't get a job
anywhere do you think that california
making it i think what they did was made
it illegal to have people not be
employees but to be contractors for oh
yeah writers and vloggers that was a
good or a bad move bad move
it wiped out so much of their digital
industry it's whole it's it's it's
laughable big bad
it was the unions that pushed for this
bill
did you hear about this in california
so this was i think like two years ago
or more longer the unions pushed for
this bill that said companies can't
contr hire contractors for a certain
amount of tasks
and so this would result in like uber
having to hire people i think i don't i
think uber may have got an amendment
that defeated or something but it meant
that if you if you uh were a writer a
freelance writer you could only write
like 30 articles per year or something
like that it was like a month yeah
it was a really low amount yeah so like
the average person might write like five
or six articles per day now you can only
do 30. well the company and the
california company just says okay your
contract's terminated the guy in arizona
who can write the same thing for me and
he can work all day every day because
arizona doesn't have those laws
or or actually what it was is companies
in new york fired all of their
california contractors and freelancers
just overnight all these it was it was
like sb nation a vox company like
terminated all of their california
freedom it just doesn't synergize with
the covet narrative of work from home
well this was before coming yeah it was
a fork of it i wonder if it was like a
prep for this kind of contingency
i don't know the working from home thing
changed my life i used to work always on
location and then in 2010 i started
working with mines we just kind of
worked from our laptops from a starbucks
or wherever
and man the commute is really draining i
don't know you you say you take your
electric bike to work now that might
that might be kind of refreshing 20
minutes it's fun but still even if i
didn't actually have to make that 20 or
30 minute trip why would i exactly
especially if i could pay 1 000 in rent
instead of 12 000 in rent then why would
i not do that i think a lot of this is
driven by economics more than it is by
crime so but you you have you have a
physical location in new york city right
unfortunately
so people have to physically walk in and
hand you something to fix so you can't i
mean you could theoretically do the
remote if what you bought something in
the middle of nowhere and said ship me
your phone and i'll fix it yeah but that
would still require the employees to
commute to that location and do the job
yeah i just mean for like new york city
like your job requires you to be a
service on the ground in new york city
for people of new york city
some think you're we're not going to be
able to you know automate or remote or
whatever some things are never going to
really be remote fully remote but a lot
of stuff is
does this you know has has it forced you
to spend more money or i'm sorry to
charge more money for your services in
new york city like the fact that
industry you know all these buildings
are shut down less people are working
unemployment's very very high
you having to have a physical
brick-and-mortar location i'd assume
costs are going up right my cost when
all my prices went up in 2012 when i
opened a real store rather than just you
know work out of the park or anything
like that i haven't raised my prices
anymore now because when people lose
their jobs and everything else costs
more money they tend to not want to
spend more money on their repairs if
your grocery bill is twice as much and
you just lost your job from covid you're
probably not if anything people were
asking for discounts non-stop in 2020 in
early 2021 but have your costs gone up
now in the past couple of years with
pandemic my costs haven't gone up as a
business they went up
not because of the what happened but
because i moved in 2019 at pretty much
the worst possible time i almost tripled
my rent at the worst possible time
because business was doing this and then
literally i move and then it's like
but food prices are up as well i mean
food and gas and everything is up that's
got to have an impact on your business
right personal uh personal yes for the
business now really i just feel like in
in the long run from this
all of it points towards certain things
are gonna become more expensive certain
things are gonna become cheaper things
that have to be physical will probably
get more expensive and things that don't
have to be will probably get cheaper i
don't see how rents can get any more
expensive in new york city but it
continues to i know what how are is it
gonna get to a point where they're like
hey no one lives here anymore let's just
drop the rent back down to i don't
believe anybody i don't think anything
there is supposed to be rented like this
started as a i didn't i didn't even
intend for this to be like a real video
series i just was looking for a new
store in 2019 and i was so aggravated
that every time i'd see a place they
lied about i said i'm going to buy one
of those little laser measurers and i'm
going to record the next time what do
they lie about well they would say it
was 800 square feet i would show up and
it would be 800 and then i would just i
have my camera and i go okay so this
says 800 you said 1800 why and that
video series is probably the most
successful thing i've ever done on
youtube like 99 of my channel probably
doesn't even know that i fixed macbooks
they just see me as a real estate person
because of that but all of these a lot
of these places they would say you know
if you don't rent it it will be rented
next week we have all these clients
lined up and then i'll show up a year or
two or three years later and it's all
empty and it's
so why don't you lower the price like a
little bit you have spaces that are the
size of my store which was 12 500 when i
first rented it they were going for 75
000 a month and it's the same size as my
location just two blocks this way and
they still won't be rented three or four
or five years later and more and more of
the city looks like this and the prices
never go down with anything the office
you know the uh the office prices stay
like that and they stay empty so this
was happening before kovid like the fact
i there was just something needed to
happen to kind of prick this little
bubble so
has it gotten better or it's still
getting worse or what no i mean i still
walk by these places every day are they
owned by mega corps that are writing off
the losses on their taxes or something i
have no idea the best thing
the best thing that i can imagine was
this uh one gentleman i'll quote on
reddit laminar flow who was saying that
a lot of these properties let's say the
mortgage will be owned by a bunch of
investors as a commercial
mortgage-backed security and i'm
probably miss phrasing this because i've
read it a year and a half ago but you
can't simply if the
if you lower the rents in the property
the value of it goes down the value of
it goes down well your collateral is the
actual building which means that the
owner of the property would have to give
up that amount of money or you'd just
you know
well no that'd be default on the
mortgage you'd you'd write off your
losses you could you could save money on
taxes by doing that no you you can't if
you actually advertise the bill at the
space at a lower rent it winds up saying
meaning that the building is worth less
and if the building is worth less than
your own oh but if you have a mortgage
on it your collateral is the building so
then you so let's say the building is
worth three million now it's worth two
well you as the building owner need to
now give the bank one million dollars in
collateral in cash or in something else
i don't i don't i don't think that's
true i mean i have mortgages and stuff
i did read this on reddit and i do think
it is possible for mortgages to call in
if the value of the house drops too low
in the bank panics but i'm but i'm not
sure exactly how that works i don't know
how it works with commercial
mortgage-backed securities it was the
closest thing that sounded like it made
any sense but i can't pretend i know i
think what might be happening right now
is
prices
because uh demand is is low prices
actually are dropping but the reason you
see the rent staying you know going up
going up is because inflation is
actually outpacing the rate at which the
building should be decreasing in value
based on supply and demand
you know what i mean
you know
a lot of these spaces are still going
for 100 to 500 a square foot yeah and
it's like that that doesn't make sense
that did that didn't even make sense
before covey because before covet these
spaces were all empty so after covert
one if people have left then it
definitely doesn't make sense well
before covet it's just new york prime
real estate you're going to hold on to
it because it's valuable during covid
everything was you know decreasing in
value but inflation was actually getting
really really bad and it's been
consistently bad every month at for the
past what six months every month it's
like inflation is at a record inflation
is at a new record inflation it's like
inflation hasn't been as high this high
since the 80s since the 80s and it's
it's going up every a little bit if you
actually do the calculation based on the
80s numbers then uh inflation right now
is actually the worst spent since world
war ii
then you also see the accusations i
think it might have been thomas massey
who said this
uh nancy pelosi and pelosi included a 21
congressional budget increase
either that means she's giving everybody
like a big raise during a crisis or to
cover the cost of inflation for their
congressional budgets they just did a 21
increase which says a whole lot about
what inflation might actually be
so if the the actual demand for these
places is non-existent or gone down
dramatically
then it should go from a hundred dollars
a square foot to maybe 30 hours a square
foot right then inflation hits and it
spikes right back up because new york
and things are just getting crummy even
if it was 20 inflation if it went from
100 to 30 then it should only go up to
let's say 36 or 38 or 40. but i mean
like new york is it has a substantially
higher cost of living so
going from 100 to 30 was just me being
hyperbolic yeah if it goes from 100 to
like you know 80 85 and then it jumps up
another 16 it goes back up to 100.
so
inflation i mean maybe that's i'm just
speculating to be completely honest i i
honestly don't know where we're going to
go from here because i think you know
almost all work we're seeing now from
most of the millennial generation and
lower is just not real work
you know to be honest
what we're doing is work like we you
know we show up i read the news all day
every day so i know stuff and i and i
and i read all this stuff
but man it's kind of crazy to me that we
sit in a room talking about things and
it generates revenue yeah and i can buy
food with it man i don't make bread i
don't farm anything that's wild there
are people who work at buzzfeed who like
i said right about brad pitt's junk or
whatever and they make sixty thousand
dollars a year and that's crazy because
the dude loading the plane i swear i
think we're very close to some kind of
you know occupy style
revolt or whatever maybe this will be a
catalyst in the civil war or something
like that
that
the people who load planes so that you
can travel around get paid probably 15
bucks an hour at this point yet the
dudes sitting in an office in new york
with a finger up their nose wondering
like how can i call trump racist today
is getting paid forty dollars an hour
yeah that that is mind-blowing to me
something something doesn't make sense
yeah certainly i think working-class
people are going to lose it just be like
i am done with whatever this is i mean
think about this let's say you work
as you know at an airline
and i i say this job because i did it
and we got paid 10 bucks an hour back in
like 2008 let's say you're working that
job and you're getting 15 bucks an hour
right now or maybe even 20 still and
then you're doing this job and you look
up in that plane and you're thinking to
yourself like you know truth be told
when you work with these companies you
get to fly for free you get to you could
you have to pay the taxes on it but you
get non-rev flights standby but you're
wondering like what is that guy up there
doing that 25 year old dude with those
thick black framed glasses what does he
do for a living that he gets to fly on
this trip to nassau to go to the bahamas
man i wish i could do that here i am
doing all of this hard back breaking
work 50 000 pounds per day loading these
planes and i don't make enough money to
go on these vacations and who's that guy
i wonder what his job is now these guys
are probably assuming like must be a
tech guy must be a finance guy and then
the dude up there with the black framed
glasses is like brad pitt's junk was
seen in a movie today and he's making
all that money so he can fly to the
bahamas like this system is broken if
you were to ask me yeah i have a feeling
that the mega corps are coming to buy
all the land not all the land but a lot
of property like black rock um state
street they're gonna buy up a bunch of
property and then there may be a revolt
an american revolt against the corporate
land owners because it's like you may
own it on paper but if you're not there
you don't really have control of the
property um they'll have private
security and then it's up to is the
american government going to support the
corporations and the the law that says
that they own it or are they going to
support the people and the freedom
against corporate monopoly because if
you want to print 80 trillion dollars
and then give it to blackrock to buy 80
trillion worth of property before
inflation and then destroy the economy
blackrock doesn't get to own that
property you will owe nothing and you
will be happy well i suspect what's more
likely to foment a revolution because
this infuriated me and i'm incredibly
patient
with something like the bloomberg
opinion talking about ways to save money
some of the things you can do are not
treat your pet if they have cancer take
the bus and eat lentils instead of meat
so what did it actually say not treat
your pet if they literally said that wow
look sooner or later you all will
realize you will own nothing and you'll
be happy also lentils are banging by the
way that's fine yeah lentils are fine
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8pm and
if you want more special access content
head over to timcast.com and become a
member your membership helps sustain
this company keep our journalists
employed makes this show happen and you
will get access to exclusive members
only segments of the tim cast irl
podcast and there is a massive library
to check out so again go to timcast.com
or tune in monday through friday at 8pm
and we'll see you all there
you